[Musica]
salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
quanto tempo è passato dall'ultima un
mese circa
noi che ero impegnato come un'altra cosa
che non mi lasciava andare
taci comunque oggi voglio recensì un
film di una categoria che raramente ho
toccato e questa giornata infatti è
chiamata la giornata dei film
indipendenti dove la gente non ha soldi
ma ci prova comunque un film lo
recensisco qui un film nel secondo
canale troverete il video come disposto
a questo qui
il film che necessita oggi e in the
market un film horror circa del 2009
diretto da lorenzo lombarde di questo
film ne ho sentito parlare un sacco me
l'avete consigliato in tanti e in più
avevo già visto la recensione del buon
vecchio victor l'asl 88 se volete vedere
una vera e propria recensione di questo
film andato a vedere quella di victor e
che potrete trovare come video risposta
a questa qui è come riassumere quello
che pensa di questo film victor l'asl 88
perché i ragazzi un film così schifoso e
raramente ho visto questo prima è la
parodia della merda è una sgommata nella
mutandole cinema è un qualcosa di
veramente a croce
parliamo con la brava a più avanti nella
recensione mi servirà questo poi vedrete
perché il film inizia come un video
musicale degli anni 80
[Musica]
forza ragazzi su queste mani ed è subito
putridume time
questo è il primissimo dialogo del film
salve mi scusi non so se potrà darmi una
mano
forse lo mezzo reparto ha ragione
questo non è il succo di fragola la
mitica
ma lo stesso grazie e che non sono di
qui sa dove posso trovare la lettera
[Musica]
ricordando lo è anche peggio di quel che
mi ricordavo ci vuole un analisi
approfondita perché è scritto in questo
modo stranissimo dovrebbe in teoria
essere un dialogo normale molto naturale
ma dicono delle cose senza senso
salve mi scusi non so se potrà darmi una
mano
forse la mezza reparto ha ragione resto
non è succo di fragola
ok di solito i film indipendenti hanno
una recitazione che si avvicina il film
porno ma queste imbrachi proprio debbano
saltarsi addosso vicenda da un momento
all'altro e forse ho sbagliato reparto e
cercavo frutta e verdura se vuole glielo
do gli un cetriolo
ma c'è un motivo per cui parte questa
scena di tensione quando lei chiede lo
zucchero sa dove posso trovare la severa
[Musica]
da questa scena si può evincere che lo
zucchero e il nemico principale del film
sa dove posso trovare lo zucchero
[Musica]
e siamo soltanto due minuti dopo quella
introduzione il film ci porta a
conoscere i tre protagonisti dei ragazzi
che viaggiano in auto non è un paese per
vecchi ma ancora non si sono sviluppati
i personaggi e già li odio stacco
improvviso verso un uomo che guarda a
prova di morte di quentin tarantino
creato lui si ritorna sui protagonisti
che ci intrattengono con degli
appassionanti discorsi che ne pensate
delle uova
affascinante la prima scena di
salvataggio da torena non scherzava in
fatto di sangue mai visto a stare e chi
non l'ha visto però non regge il
paragone può spingerli anche perché sono
due generi diversi infatti uno si basa
su fatti realmente accaduti mentre
l'altro è pura fantasia davvero hostel e
salvate il soldato ryan sono due generi
completamente diversi
mi avete aperto un mondo allora che cosa
mangia un animale venerdì sentiamo i
pescatori divertente se non fosse per il
fatto che non è divertente e qui entra
in scena questo lo riempirò con dei
pezzi di carta ogni volta che c'è una
scena in utile potete immaginare come
andrà a finire
per uno scherzo il ragazzo scende le
ragazze di partono ma poi lo tornano a
prendere così ad un certo punto si
fermano per fare benzina e le due
ragazze ne approfittano per farsi
leggere le carte da una cartomante
c'è freddo freddo tanto freddo il giorno
diventa notte invece dal rosso per
favore sta zitta e tutti ci stiamo
chiedendo a cosa serve la scena della
cartomante perché le ragazze vanno a
farsi leggere le carte
ma all'improvviso arrivano due
rapinatori che giustamente rapinano il
benzinaio solo punto ma di fatto un c e
questo vuol dire che giudica resto dei
soldi gay ma chi è che parlerebbe così
durante una rapina
tra l'altro complimentoni per la
maschera di mimì e io avrei preferito
quella di olivia di braccio di ferro ma
sono gusti la cosa spettacolare che
questa rapina non serve assolutamente a
nulla ai fini della trama
a questo punto infatti vi chiederete ma
la trama dove si staranno dirigendo i
nostri eroi di fare un viaggio senza
meta da nessuna cazzo di parte ma che
bello ma andando avanti viaggiano ancora
con la macchina che palle diosanto sta
roba iniziano a tirare un po troppo per
le lunghe
ora sono diretti verso un market aperto
tutto il giorno che può sembrare poco ma
credetemi se paragonato a tutto quello
che abbiamo visto adesso è un colpo di
scena
il ragazzo ha una brillante idea quella
di farsi chiudere dentro il market per
fare razzia di tutto quanto a cosa ci
serve una stupida camera dell'hotel
tutti noi ma perché
che idea di merda e farsi chiudere
dentro e bravi da degli anti corda
mentecatti ma poi come farete a farmi
chiudere dentro ci aspettiamo ma certo
chiusi in bagno ma è ovvio imbecilli
adesso arriva l'inserviente di scava
subito visto
cos'è successo l'inserviente sta per
aprire la porta si ferma e va a
specchiarsi così a caso di merda chi fa
male detto così appena spente le luci si
mettono seduti a mangiare
nel frattempo si raccontano storie di
paura è la storia di una bambina che
aveva un cane dal quale non si separava
mai
i suoi genitori erano spesso fuori di
casa per lavoro e la lasciavano con il
fratello maggiore che però non la
considerava una bambina ogni sera
metteva la mano sotto il letto per
farsela le gare da giocare
così facendo si tranquillizzava e sapeva
di non essere sola
mentre del milan
il tuono cade vicino alla casa io avrei
la domanda perché mi fate perdere tempo
ma porca eva sono 43 minuti 43 minuti
che non succede nulla che non va avanti
la trama ma non doveva essere un film
horror questo quei all orrore sta nel
riuscire a guardarlo senza suicidarsi
sapete quante cose si possono fare in 43
minuti si può visitare un vero centro
commerciale fare una missione di skyrim
buttarsi giù da un ponte
due volte di fila ed è tutto molto
meglio che subirsi questa tortura
psicologica comunque scoprono di non
essere da soli nel market è finalmente
con loro c'è un torturatore che li
scopre subito ovviamente vengono
catturati tutti la prima cosa siamo io e
te una seconda i tuoi occhi
la terza un pensiero
la quarta è la notte che sta dicendo
corpi straziati la sesta infame
ma lei che cresce dentro
e morte aveva avere un infarto
la settima e l'orrore che verrà si ok
però adesso stai un po esagerando
dottore ferito non so neanche capendo
cosa dici thaci dai fantasmi telefonia
che fioriscono su questo macello posto
ma cosa ciò ha colpita per tutto sandra
formato certo se ci ciato di agonia
i vivi si aggirano derubando i divi
dell'essere vivi tutti
[Musica]
po sta iniziando a torturarmi bene
chiedo scusa non vorrei disturbare ma
non dovrebbe iniziare a segare tagliare
far spruzzare sangue ovunque a torturare
non voglio certo mancare di rispetto e
solo che sto iniziando a rompermi
leggermente i [ __ ] di sentirla far
medicare a caso anche perché non sto
capendo nulla
oggigiorno la gente non compra più qui
siamo in un market no eh vabbè
a che punto siamo
[Musica]
sono tornato giusto in tempo e
finalmente vediamo qualcosa di vagamente
horror le taglia un pezzo di carne per
farlo mangiare a lui malatissimo devo
dire che questa parte di film mi piace
non poteva essere tutto così peccato sia
rovinata dalla recitazione di lui ma
come redditi mentre il macellaio taglia
a pezzi la ragazza lui vede una via di
fuga cerca di liberarsi ma cade dalla
sedia e il macellaio lo pulisce
disintegrando gli una mano
ale la terza ragazza intanto riesce a
fuggire prende la jeep e scappa a gambe
levate
così facilmente mi sembra strano infatti
e sul frutto della sua immaginazione in
realtà lei è ancora lì
nel finale vediamo il macellaio che
vende la carne nel market
probabilmente la carne dei tre ragazzi
dei punti macabri ssimo mi piace e
durante piccolo monologo finale del
macellaio ancora ma basta c'è un fermo
immagine talmente inutile che pensavo
che si fosse rovinato il film tavole
imbandite gli animali che siamo
sa dove posso trovare lo zucchero
[Musica]
comunque questo era in the market che
dire è un film indipendente quindi per
quanto brutto sia forse non bisogna
andarci così tanto pesante ma è una
sgommata nella muta delle cinema è un
qualcosa di veramente atroce appunto mi
sono piaciuti soltanto gli ultimi dieci
minuti di film il resto è noia e
citazioni un sacco di citazioni ad altri
film e tra l'altro riassumiamo
brevissimamente la trama in in the
market tre ragazzi viaggiano in auto
senza meta finiscono casualmente in una
rapina ai danni di un benzinaio vanno in
un market aperto 24 ore su 24 per farsi
chiudere dentro è dentro questo market
c'è un macellaio che ammazza le persone
e ne rivende la carne
e questo rende in the market come come
come completamente inutile la recensione
finisce qui io come al solito vi
ringrazio di tutti gli iscritti tutti i
commenti tutti i complimenti che mi fate
vi ricordo se volete vedere una vera e
propria recensione del film di guardare
la recensione di victor l'asl 88 e se
volete iscrivervi al suo canale è sempre
come rivideo risposta di questo video
qui la recensione di un altro film
indipendente che per però questa volta
mi è piaciuto del gherber syndrome
ci vediamo ad una prossima recensione